I look down at my leg just because I
thought my foot went through the canvas
I didn't know what the hell was
happening I looked down I looked back up
and I see him looked down at my leg and
that was that's really when okay this is
my time now when you're walking to the
ring first you you've got to be focused
obviously but you can't be getting too
much into the moment too soon so you've
got to kind of enjoy it embrace it I had
this sort of seek and destroy feeling I
just couldn't wait to get in there and
get him out of there got there let my
hands go and knock him out
I love that music I've grown up on that
music that's the kind of music that was
constantly on in my house when I was
growing up I could tiny been you loving
the song knows all the words to it you
know you can say what you want about
Tony value and his personality your good
taste in music he's actually dancing I
remember seeing him dancing from afar
alright so when he walks to the ring I'm
enjoying this ring walk but this time we
have a difference because guess what
he's working first what he's doing in
the ring is what I normally do and
they're soaked up and enjoy it and get
into the vibe I wasn't others all wrong
Viper's wall rock they were those usual
comes out would be you know the
intimidation tactics all I'm thinking is
I can't wait to hit this idiot on the
chin and yeah they can't wait to do that
he wants to take center stage he wants
to take center ring straightaway comes
out with a long way loose last time tiny
bellies nice and lively a lot more
lively than it usually is his feet a
good fast feet way faster than mine here
I usually start with a very relaxed
manner but I've started this fish on
switched on waiting at the David two
pumps because I know he's gonna try he
looks at the big swing straightaway he's
willing to exchange straightaway banger
left off lands and able to leave but
he's felt my left hook totally bellies
hit me with a left hook there that sort
of knocked me off balance I remember
think to myself at the time thank god
this guy can't hit because I've been hit
by Klitschko and value Evans and Giants
and if I'd have been hit with them shots
and if I'd have been hit with a shot
that he hit live in that first round the
bare minimum it would have shook me to
my boots and worried me I've just made
them miss by a mile I've just made up
I'm making Tony bellies with like Turner
Whitted I look like Sugar Ray Robinson
in there genuinely he's looking he's
looking like an all-time great against
me see this is the reason why David did
you just walk me down David didn't feel
my power two tours why didn't he just
walk straight in and knock here while
I'm hitting with the energy wasn't let's
find the right shot it's just Ruth earth
I'm gonna hit you and miss like a
complete and utter amateur I've got
better food than him
my feet are what other keys in his face
as he makes the short steps I make the
slight the quick adjustments you know
you swing them big right hooks to me
body to each office just outside some on
time and he's out of range I'm so right
now I'm watching this and I'm printing
myself how lucky am i is that I'm in the
minute timer because and the stakes are
making in the heavyweight division
should see you unconscious I'm not
likely to exchange any point of my flap
I ain't running from day okay I'm stood
right in front of me can't hit me I had
the tactics right on the night
ultimately I know a favor this he's a
very fast very dangerous puncher but
he's someone who runs out of ideas when
he's struggling to find the target and
I'm not and I'm an elusive puncher
meself he's winning every second at this
first round
everything I've thrown is crude and just
terrible and everything he's done has
looked very Compton and very classy
right now he's the matador and I'm the
bull running at him and Easy's let me go
round and round it I'm probably the
quickest fighter he's ever fought and
I'm not known for any kind of good eat
amount of speed that I have he's got a
fantastic job which is but you doesn't
use as much as you used to
I remember you threw one right hand to
my body and I'm moving in he's really
can't punch I'm gonna put my hand down
again and letting him do it again just
to see if he's punch was that soft but
it generally was I'm thinking okay so
he's supposed to be this big body punch
or everything and if that's him with the
right hand to the body got nothing
really to worry about boys c'mon so this
heat I didn't perform I didn't do this
well you didn't perform ty didn't allow
you to the thing he didn't get off the
shot off because I didn't stand straight
with me
waned using it I bought [ __ ] pleats
hit and he pops like a very very
cultured boxer Dave's told me to sit
down stay focused and I've said to be
Carney and they both look like they'd
won the lottery there then we're looking
they're like we couldnít I remember
Shane said they were you doing what are
you doing okay good okay okay good got
out of my system now you see Joshua
clapping me
he knows that supports my all support
him a judge from the mind looking back
going over the official score cards I'd
lost the first round I'd won round two
three four and five and going into this
sixth round I felt like things were kind
of settling down
the kamati for the sixth round I've once
again come out took sense of the ring
and popping jabs are now in David's
range now and he isn't he's reluctant to
throw you know he's obviously thinking
about gases started calming down a bit
it's like picking my shots just couple
more faints you know fighting punches
were really useless position here tiny
belly's distended bellies Tony Tony
bellies doing well he's he's doing
everything he needs to do you know he's
he's hanging on in there at this stage
right off and David
and here we go I think this is where the
injury comes not
maybe this one the good job there
David's got his hands open he's trying
to measure me all the time
very unlike David Hayter that ball comes
off after talking to the counter right
hand over the top
so you see called fluff - all 10 points
good right hand landed by maybe it's now
turned into the boxing match which I
want wanted it to be its and I'm
standing I'm standing my ground david
missed by a mile again so the whatever
men is I step back and I heard an
almighty crunch I looked down at my leg
just cuz I thought my foot went through
the canvas I didn't know what the hell
was happening I looked down and looked
back up and I see him look down at my
leg and that was that's when he went
okay this is my time now I'd won the
last four rounds guy and seth godin is
that six round but this was his time so
I remember thinking the [ __ ] you scan
he's coming at me now I don't know why
could I can't really fly right ham
normally I'm gonna try and chuck a big
right hand for a big big left sort
cuffing left hooks with that of the open
hand and somehow it caught in court and
ran the side of the head an addicting
hair butch caught me and I've gone down
off a head clash David Hayes the
injuries are cared now
[Applause]
I've attached to your stand on my feel
I'm not sure feel I [ __ ] up when you
turn your heel it turns your hip out so
you can't throw right hands properly so
all the right hands are gonna be sort of
arm punches but our fort [ __ ] it I'm not
gonna just the more gonna quit no way
softly okay this just [ __ ] you know it
I'm swinging for the lights I'm London
right hand off the right on there's a
big weight um for me now it's a walk
it's quite a pipe battle eggnog
definitely not given a knock down there
I don't think it was enough karma it was
he give us the straight a strange
experience before okay they just keep
swinging big of a right-handed is
literally fell over
I'm think to myself the fight is gonna
be stopped any minute so I just have to
just throw everything I'd like to save
the injured he's there there for
everyone to see what he's still swinging
for the lights caught him with a big
right on their baby tree limb the pace
he's feeling the power big right hand
big left or big wait I'm on the ropes
he's down this time where there's a
knockdown I remember sitting down and
having that reflective moment thinking
okay right then your kilise tendon
snapped
you've got a fight in front of you who's
coming at you friend all guns blazing
this is this is that this is where
you're gonna need to dig deep this is
when this is what champions are made of
this is you're gonna have to win this
fight and win it on one leg I've wound
them up in the put in the build-up to
the last phase I've said don't new
spirit on me don't quit that's just much
on revival the composers David hey it's
not a coward no man who gets in a box
and then could possibly be a coward
the instructions were you know so
basically sit on the ropes and tried to
catch into a counter punch but I see it
so in the sixth round don't need to see
any more because whatever happened from
round 6 onwards is never going to happen
ever again
and it'd be a waste of time even
analyzing it
around the Lebanon I've made David mess
with a big wide left hook I'm China and
navigating to the ropes because that's
where these I was vulnerable so I wanted
to attack police China take center stage
and just jab I'm just trying to edge him
back he's landed a good counter right
down there right I've got him to the
ropes
I go in I show him a little faint down
upon which are big left or big right
hand
big left on the side yet he's worthy
he's got one leg off
Shaima Wiggins seen enough he sees David
get what David wants to carry on
fighting book I've dropped him his legs
have gone beneath him the balance is now
completely gone it's not like where he
was standing and swing and punches
before I hear something up and it's now
getting dangerous so we're you know
Shane comes into all the talent and the
rest is history a disappointment way for
me to end the fight
[Applause]